les faits se sont déroulés à 23h57 nuit
un homme à bord d'un véhicule c3 dans
lequel se trouvaient trois autres
personnes a reculé sur les clients
amassés sur la terrasse d'un bar à bière
il semblerait qu'un groupe de jeunes
fêtards s'amuser à taper sur les
voitures et aurait fait paniquer le
conducteur ce dernier a ensuite pris la
fuite en forçant le barrage de clients
tentant de l'arrêter
il sera finalement interpellé à la
chapelle de guinchay quelques kilomètres
plus loin
lors d'un contrôle d'alcoolémie positif
le bilan est lourd mais aurait pu être
beaucoup plus grave
seize personnes ont été blessées dont
une plus sérieusement touché aux jambes
mais sa vie ne serait pas en danger
les victimes ont été conduites dans les
hôpitaux de mâcon bourg-en-bresse
villefranche et chalon au total 46
pompiers venus du mâconnais de la ont
été mobilisés sur cette intervention de
grande ampleur le chauffard a été placé
en garde à vue pour s'expliquer sur son
acte l' enquête a été confiée à la
brigade de recherches de mâcon